hello everyone
and welcome to today's live webinar
impact of
liquid biopsy in advanced her2 positive
breast cancer
tumors a follow-up study i'm christian
love labyrinths
and i'll be your moderator for today's
event today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by labyrinth
and sponsored by thermo fisher
scientific for more information on our
sponsor
please click on the thermo fisher logo
at the left side of your screen
now let's get started i would like to
remind everyone that today's event is
interactive
and we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box
and click send we will answer as many of
your questions as we have time for
at the end of the presentation if you
have any trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation click on the
support tab found at the top
right of your presentation window or
report your problem by using that ask a
question box
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits i would now like to introduce to
you today's speaker
dr matteo allegretti postdoctoral fellow
for a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab
at the top of your screen welcome dr
alegretti you may now begin
your presentation
good morning everyone thanks for the
introduction christy
before i start i would like to thank
thermo fisher to give me
this opportunity to share our experience
in the liquid biopsy field particularly
within metastatic breast
cancer these are my
disclosure
okay let's start for those of you who
are not
pretty familiar with breast cancer i
will briefly introduce this tumor and
what are the main
issues in the clinic related to the
emergence of resistance
then we will address the benefits of
liquid biopsy that are rapidly
transforming this technique in
powerful non-invasive tool for mutation
detection
taking over time and therapy assignment
in different
clinical settings and finally
i will show you some unpublished data
from
a national multi-centric study we are
performing here in italy
in which we investigated whether liquid
biopsy may help in clinical monitoring
of advanced breast cancer patients
undergoing
underlines of therapy
as probably you know breast cancer is
one of the five big killer in the world
and it's generally recognized as the
first leading cause of death for women
according to the last epidemiological
estimates
more than one million adults of new
cases are
annually diagnosed in the world without
a million
about half a million or women dying for
disease
with the groundbreaking work of peru
and colleagues at the beginning of this
millennium
breast cancers have to be considered to
consist
at least of four main entities
four different subtypes bearing specific
and clinically relevant features
i highlight in the red box four iso
types
and from this cartoon you can easily see
the main feature of each group
according to this classification we can
easily stratify
patient outcome demonstrating that
molecular features have a direct impact
on survival and prognosis therefore
huge effort have been made to deeply
understand the genetics of breast cancer
and today
up to 10 different clusters are being
characterized by using
jinkobi number expression analysis
especially on tissue samples and saline
unfortunately these evidences are not
rapidly translatable into the clinic due
to
high costs and the need of specific
requirements
and the main thing i focus still relying
on
mutational analysis for outcome
prediction and therapy assignment
as i show you among breast cancer there
is a specific group of
patients that display a two over
expression
they generally account for 20 percent of
total cases and are particularly of
interest
because they generally have aggressive
disease
and poor prognosis over the past
decade the management of air to positive
breast cancer patients dramatically
evolved
because several targeted agents
including monoclonal antibodies small
molecule and abc
have been developed a recent pastry
studies
randomized facebook studies have shown
that the addition of this drug to chemo
significantly improved pfs and overall
survival both in
primary and metastatic settings
here you can see what have the approved
strategy
for the f2 subtype despite a good
response to first line generally the pfs
and overall response
rate drop down when we move to second
third or later lines of
treatment due to the emergence of
resistant claw
this cartoon shows you the biological
process that are targeted by the air to
blockade
has been shown that roughly all of this
pathway
may develop alteration during the
natural history of the tumor
leading to resistance and ultimately to
treatment failure okay now
why liquid biopsy of course
many of you already know the answer
because the user body fluids offer
several advantages over conventional
biopsy
this is a list of the main feature of
tissue biopsy as compared to liquid
biopsy
i don't want to go in detail but i'd
like to underline that in a real world
generally we cannot repeat the tissue
bias yet probably need
and in many cases issues simple are
really
insufficient or not available at all
representing the big issue to understand
what is going on in the patient liquid
biopsy may overcome
many of these programs offering a real
comprehensive picture of the molecular
landscape of the tumor
particularly we are interested in
spatial and temporal heterogeneity
this feature is progressively emerging
as
the most important thing to modulate
therapy assignments over time ultimate
cancer
for this reason liquid bias is being
progressively applied into the clinic
both in advance and early setting
as you can see from this representative
timeline
as part of a molecular lab one of the
most important thing
before starting a simple profiling is to
select the optimal technique to answer a
specific question
but as you know tumors are dynamic
entities and during their naturally 30
day evolve
therefore it's also necessary to
maintain
such a high flexibility in the workflow
we use
we can face for example with different
questions
like why metastasis emerge or
why a specific patient respond and
eventually relax after year each of the
great step that i highlighted
here in the slide can be easily taken by
using the right technology
basically in every setting we should
prefer
high-sensitivity techniques like
multiplex digital pcr to address low
frequencies
while only onset of the tumor we can be
interested in understanding the key
feature of the cancer
altogether and we should prefer
high-throughput
platform like ngs during therapy
multiple samples may be also available
so we need to adopt a strategy that
minimize cost and maximize the output
and finally we may address tumor
herogenity by using again ngs
better understand what would be the best
strategy for this patient
today different solutions are available
on the market
for liquid biopsy they essentially rely
on ngs both targeted or amplicon-based
and digital pcr both workflows started
with nuclei acid
extraction and are made of really simple
evidence
strapped forward from simple preparation
to data reporting
here you can see some example of the
steps
that are needed to achieve a result
with this technique now
i would like to share with you our
experience on
breast cancer we investigated the
clinical feasibility of liquid bias in
the
f2 positive subgroup by establishing
this multicentric study here in italy
that involved several cancer issues
across the country
by the by collaborating with irk the
italian association of
cancer research and jim the italian
group for breast cancer
in this project we firstly assess
human tissue samples to list index
mutation
and then we sequentially analyze by
combining
ngs digital pcr approach a collection of
serial blood samples we obtained during
the trigger follow-up of the patient
in order to quantify the impact that
liquid biopsy could have if applied in a
real
clinical setting today
we enrolled 51 cases 20 of which were
fully characterized at design
with respect to molecular feature tissue
samples were
available for all most of the cases so
we were able to obtain a
contractualization of the initial tumor
profile
more than 300 blood samples were collect
during the follow-up of the patient with
a mean of 15 blood samples per case
regarding the technical aspect in the
blood
we run about 100 punk answer essays
and in this blue box i show
you an overview of the data we obtained
i would like to focus your attention on
two main points the first the percentage
of cases
that liquid bias is called as positive
at baseline and at
relapse that was around 65
75 and the second
the performance of the sc in terms of
median
limit of detection we obtained by using
as
inputs just about 20 nanograms of
circulating
total nucleic acid but most importantly
for us
was the concordance with clinical
outcome as defined viruses criteria
as you can see in the box below
80 percent of our liquid biopsy data
correlated with the clinical response
obtained by the patient and i will show
you some example of that in the next
week's life
as to digital pcr the vast majority of
the work was performed to design and
validate customers
because the majority of me we packed
in tissue were not so common
here the percentage of the positive case
was a little bit higher as compared to
ngs
but this was expected also by using
lower amount of dna as input
the concordance with clinical and ngs
data
remain very high as you can see in the
box
in the last part of the
blue table we notice
only a drop when we explore very low
variant allele frequency but it is
largely expected to the difference in
sensitivity
by the two platform okay okay now
i will show you some representative
example from our collection
the first case i would like to introduce
come from a women
with a very aggressive disease she
underwent surgery
in 2017 and she was diagnosed
with a so-called trigger positive
metastatic breast cancer
she started immediately as this line a
dual blockade
and two antibodies but unfortunately
she relapsed before the year then
she moved to tedium 1 but again the
progression was very fast
during this period we have the
possibility to serially simple blood
and to have access to the tissue biopsy
of the primitive tumor
the ngs analysis shows the presence of
one of the most common categories has a
high
very very high frequency in the tissue
the same mutation was found by ngs
and digital pcr at the line in the blood
and this was how it looks in
digital pcr then we analyzed sequential
blood samples
collected during the clio follow-up of
the patient
recording this trend over time
a huge escalation as you can see by the
graph of the variant allele frequency
was found until clinical relapses
as you can see by the red bar
ngs and digital when combining
the same time showed the same value
in the same blood sample but
what was very important for us was that
lipid biopsy
if we were able to test blood at the
time
of sampling may anticipate the failure
of the ongoing treatment
at least two months earlier than ct scan
then the patient went on starting a
third line therapy
we were able to simple her blood in
multiple occasions
for example after three months and yes
indigenous pcr documented a clear
reduction of the theatrical mutation
while the pet scan showed only table
disease
we repeated the analysis two times more
and after additional three months the
pet
can finally show a partial response
again liquid biopsy if applied
prosthetically would have been able to
predict the outcome
about five months earlier than
conventional clinical imaging
the patient continued treatment and
three months later we found
an increase in terms of copies per ml of
the peptic imitation
in the blood but still in the personal
stable disease as shown by pets
eight months later a huge increase of
loss
was noted by digital pcr and
ngs unfortunately at this time
we were unable to collect a clinical
result of the situation
so we probably foresee
a noble relapse in the patient but we
cannot confirm that
another example i would like to share in
terms of primary resistance
comes from this 56 years old woman
who was initially diagnosed as to
negative
she failed the first line very quickly
becoming
positive and she started a dual blockade
as a second
line but a feeling again
and she came to our attention just after
the third line therapy that
unfortunately
she failed very fast once more
tissue samples were not available for
this patient but
liquid body of your blood was able to
show the presence of one
typical 53 mutation
this mutation progressively arise over
time
demonstrating to be probably the
resistant mechanisms of the disease
to the treatment again as you can see by
this graph
liquid bias you would have been able to
predict
relapse earlier than conventional
imaging
okay now i will show you some
representative cases from our collection
the first case i would like to introduce
comes from a woman with a very
aggressive disease
she underwent surgery in 2017
and she was diagnosed with a so-called
triple positive metastatic breast cancer
she started immediately as first line
and dweller to blockade but
unfortunately she relapsed over the year
then she moved to tdm1 but again
the progression was very fast during
this period we have the possibility to
serially simple blood
and to have access to tissue biopsy of
the primitive tumor
the nds anality showed the presence of
one of the most common categories very
high frequency in the tissue
the same mutation was found by ngs and
digital pcr
in the blood at the line at very similar
buffer this was how it
looks in digital pcr
then we analyzed sequential blood
samples collected
during clinical follow-up of the patient
recording this trend
over time a huge escalation as you can
see by the graph
of the body and the lead frequency was
found until clinical relapses
as i indicated by the red bar
ngs and digital pcr when combined
shows more or less the same value in
terms of love
but what was very important for us was
that liquid biases
were able to test blood at the time of
simply
may anticipate the clinical failure of
the ongoing treatment
two months earlier than ct scan
then the patient went on starting a
third line therapy
we were able to simpler blood in
multiple occasions
for example after three months and yes
individual pcr documented a clear
reduction of the capital mutation
while the pet scan showed only stable
disease
we repeated the analysis two times more
and after additional three months the
pet scan
showed the partial response again
liquid bias if applied prospectively
would have been able to predict the
outcome of this patient about
5 months earlier than clinical imaging
then the patient continued treatment and
three months later we found an increase
in terms of copies per ml
of the caffeine mutation in the blood
but
in the presence of a stable disease
eight months later as you can see by
this
last image a huge increase of loss
was noted by digital pcr and ngs
unfortunately no clinical records were
available
at this time but probably we foresee and
nobody last
another example i would like to share in
terms of primary decisions come
from 56 years old women
was initially diagnosed as so negative
she failed the first line very quickly
becoming so positive
and she started a dual blockage as
second line therapy
but failing again she came to our
attention
after the third line therapy that
unfortunately she failed very fast once
more
tissue samples were not available in
this case but liquid biofilm blood
was able to detect the personal 1 tp33
imitation
this mutation progressively arise over
time
demonstrating to be resistant to be the
resistant mechanism to this treatment
again liquid biopsies then be able to
predict
relapse earlier than conventional
imaging
one of the key advantages of liquid
biocide tissue is the possibility to
take a picture of a precise moment
in this case we were able to analyze
multiple lesions from the patient
showing clearly
the presence selection over time of a
theatric imitation as you can see by
this table
in the last part of the slide i put some
clinical information of this case
but what i would like to stress
is that primitive and liver metastases
were collected years before the starting
of the lifetime
lost line of therapy when the patient
comes to our attention
around the liquid bias analysis and
we first we could hypothesize that
something happening the main times in
federal molecular
changes indeed by when we perform
liquid bias we were able to document
the complete absence of the same the
imitation we found in issue at this line
and also in the first two pretty far
up to the fifth blood draw we collect
from this patient the patient
unfortunately progressed
about one year later starting on therapy
and as you can see by the strand in the
blood
both ngs and digital pcr could affect a
progressive increase over science basic
communication
with a living time of 2.8 months
as compared to clinical imaging
in many cases as indeed little bios
may help to identify arising limitations
here we haven't accessed to issue
samples since
needle bias we found in the patient
were previously used for immunized
mechanics and were not available
despite the fact that liquid bias we
couldn't detect
any baseline imitation we were able to
identify an actionable
one smd right before the progression of
the station
more in general if we consider only the
relapsing cases
liquid biopsy was able to identify at
least
one operation in the blood in no
testosterone
in an average age a little time to relax
for
three months generally speaking
the most important advantage of liquid
over lipid bias approach
is to properly define tumor
interogeneity
this women have an estimated negative
disease
that probably evolve as f2 positive
in multiple size as you can see
she faced very quickly several lines of
therapy
before coming to our attention we
firstly analyzed that issue by mgs
during the presence of our imitation
the father disappeared in the skin
metaphor
in the blood that big line leaves the
pcr
and ngs was able to detect communication
on esr-1 essentially this is the pci
identifies two mutations
that were seemingly absent in this issue
one of which was not affected by the ngs
because at
very low frequency at relax
the patient developed a new exercise in
the white fights with 7m
and the clone that was originally
present at the lowest
frequency become the most prevalent
it was the strength of a sign
the patient person meant a first line of
therapy with
investment and capacity and three months
later it is done show a partial response
with 60 percent of reduction of liver
metastasis
and nuclear effusion we analyze the
corresponding blood sample
showing a clear reduction of the esr1
mutation
with the complete disappearance of the
y5c7s
the most prominent clone founders
relapsed with the third line therapy
as shown before liquid vibes may
identify in a very
simple and fast way an eventual response
to treatment
here there are three cases which we were
able to identify
clear response yet after the first two
three time points
heavily heavier than the first linear
the evaluation
i would like to focus your attention
just to case number 19
at baseline ngs panel we are the ngs
panel we
applied was able to detect only
the lb2 mutation but by using
the index that we found we previously
identified in the corresponding primary
tissue
we were able to design a specific
essay for the theatrical mutation
issue and we were able to identify
its presence in the first time points
this was just this was just an example
to remind you that issue profiling is
still
important even in the growing landscape
of liquid biopsy
of course even in the case of liquid
biopsies we can face with several issues
as you can see by this spaghetti plot in
our study the vast majority of
mutational trajectories strongly
correlate with the
clinical outcome of the patient however
in some cases like this liquid bias is
called approximately negative
some patients that really develop
progression disease
in these two specific cases progression
disease was due
for brain metabolism this was not
surprising
because the there are plenty of studies
in literature
demonstrating the inability of
blood-based analysis to properly
recapitulate the molecular feature of
brain humans or brain metabolism
but in this case however a liquid
analysis of csf
may better define human feature
moreover in other cases like these two
it happened that liquid biasing results
were not
really informative for example in the
case of simple number
six we documented a strong reduction of
the piety k in the blood
in spite of progressive disease this was
initially continuity but when we take
the biopsy from this patient from
a skin metastasis it was also it was
confirmed also in this issue
sorry suggesting that other mechanisms
were sustaining the progression we are
seeing
another great improvement of liquid
biopsy to cancer profiling
is the possibility to track the
evolution of the tumor
suggesting additional lines of therapy
as you can see here the majority of our
samples
showed at least one aberration at this
line
and some of them acquired additional
mutation and relapse
only in a minority of cases as those are
presented before
progression disease for brain metastasis
impair the
ability of liquid biopsy to identify
tumor aberration in the blood besides
the strong correlation we found between
clinical and plasma behavior
that i represent in the middle of this
table
i would like to focus your attention on
the right part of the table regarding
the
action ability according to
the last concocability criteria
in more than 60 percent of our cases
the application of liquid biosince the
cleaning would result in additional
therapeutic strategy for the oncologist
in one third of these cases specifically
this mutation we're not seeing the
corresponding tissue
probably due to the sampling time that
occurred
year and year before the initiation of
the treatment
in other words this result strongly
suggests the liquid biopsy may
complement
issue analysis in the routine
investigation undergoing for cancer
profiling
this is my last slide with some common
and take-home messages
i showed you that lipid biopsy may allow
the identification and monitoring over
time of the existing or the no-acquired
mutation
most of which could be linked to the
response or resistance of specific
treatment by doing that liquid biopsy
particularly in breast cancer strongly
correlate with the clinical outcome
giving the possibility to predict in a
very accurate
and fine way treatment responds earlier
than conventional imaging
in some cases an ngs-based approach
offer also the possibility to track
so seeking to account really a spatial
and temporary heterogeneity
as i showed before is still important to
keep in mind that tissue profiling
may help even when we are speaking about
liquid biopsy and that it's absolutely
recommend in my opinion to proceed with
a combined approach
particularly by using ngs and digital
pcr
to avoid misinterpretation of the
results due the
due to the limit of detection of each
technique we use
with this i conclude my talk and i'm
happy to take questions for you
thank you
thank you dr allegretti for your
informative presentation
we will now start our live q a portion
of the webinar
now to our audience if you have a
question you would like to ask please do
so now
just click on that ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we will answer as many questions we
have time for okay let's get started
we have several questions already coming
in dr alegretti
what are the advantages of in-house
testing
versus outsourcing to a service provider
oh there are several advantages in my
institute
since we are research clinical makes it
easy because
we just go upstairs take the sample
and proceed quickly to cloud modulation
and analysis but in our in this
project i showed you we use a
multi-center
approach so in this case we prefer
to isolate to process sample directly on
site
without going or not sorting
without going outsourcing so just
having the possibility to train the
internal personnel to store
properly to process a store properly
sample and then ship that
in general in my opinion it's preferable
to apply an internal
approach so in other words using
all the methodology like nds or other
high throughput
um platform or high sensitivity
machine like digital pcr in house
without taking without sending out
from the institute the sample because
in some cases also the management the
shipping of the sample
may alter what are the picture of the
same project
there are a lot of solutions that be
like
blood samples like tubes that contain
preservatives but
it may happen something that
the sample for example is not shifted
properly
or it comes to the final center
laboratory that is in charge of the
analysis later than
what was originally planned
so in this case it's equal to
lost the same code in general we prefer
to process and to use an internal
approach
to manage all this kind of liquid biopsy
project all these kind of liquid biopsy
related
issues
thank you dr allegretti now our next
question has two parts
how much cell-free dna or cell-free
tna did you use when you analyzed tissue
and plasma
with ngs and dpcr analysis
and what about blood how many tubes were
needed
to get this amount of material
okay as to the first question it depends
on the same code for tissue analysis
we generally base our mgs
using 10 nanograms of dna
as the input but specifically speaking
in this project we face also
some cases with less material and
we properly obtain data
also from an injector from
five or three if i remember probably 3.5
nanogram was the lowest amount we use
for tissue analysis
as to plasma it depends
also on the timing of the sample
but in general we were able to obtain
at least 20 nanograms of total nuclei
creating total nucleic acid as input and
we use this amount as
inputs for our nds analysis in some
cases
we were able also to perform the same
analysis
with up to 40
nanograms of material total material
but it happens only rarely
if i can go back on my slide
in the slide in which yes maybe if
this one if yes
i put a mean a range of
the input we use for
here that is min or
input we use for blood and gas
analysis in the blood for 240
nanograms and the median input was 22
yes these are the mean we
obtain on average also with other
cancer types like colon or
lung cancer it is we generally process
with the same approach in our and
the second question chrissy could you
repeat me the second part of the
question
absolutely what about blood how many
tubes were needed to get this amount of
material
okay it's the telling of the protocol in
this specific
project we were able to draw
from the patient up to 20 ml of inside
blood
but in other projects we are running in
the institute
our uh ethical committee uh
give us there to give us the
the authorization to process up to 30 ml
in general we were as a general
opinion why we can
process we can obtain data starting from
one tube
one ml tube of entire blood because
it's equal of 4 5
ml of plasma and we can easily obtain
the minimum amount in terms of total
nucleic acid total circulating nucleic
acids
we need to run an ngf panel
cut targeted and just fun
thank you are there any differences in
terms of cttna
yields among research samples and
different types of cancer
oh yes particularly when we are speaking
about
other types of cancers like colon
or lung cancer in our experience
we generally in my individual we are in
charge of processing
different types of liquid bias the
sample
starting from breast to thyroid cancer
colon lung and so on and
we see this kind of difference for
example
colon cancer were generally
contained generally higher number of
amounts
as compared to breast as compared to
other rate cancer like
dula retired cancer and yes
the answer is yes properly there are
some kind of tumor like gastrointestinal
tumor or in the lung some in some
cases stage 4 lung cancer that
display huge amount of cell free dna
in the bloodline so the analysis from
this kind of simple can be
defined easily then
the same analysis with the same approach
from other kind of
samples thank you dr allegretti we have
time for a few more questions
what is the criteria or the rationale
that you followed
to decide that after a series of dpcr
tests
it was necessary to perform a new ngs
test
okay it depends in this specific project
i
show you we adopt a physical uh fixed
time line of ngs analysis we run ngss
baseline at
relapse and in every occasion the
patient
underwent clinical imaging to have an
idea what's
going on in in the patient in other
projects
we generally perform an ngs analysis at
the baseline
just to have an idea of what
can lead and yes immediately the
difference
between the tissue whenever
it's available so the ngs analysis
perform on tissue
and the first time point of blood
because in general this patient comes to
our attention after several lines of
therapy
and on average the median
time of same thing of issues
is year and year before the
first time point so the first blood
analysis we perform in the patient
so uh what's the right timeline
i cannot give you a precise
answer but it depends on
friendly on the kind of tumor there are
some tumors that evolve
very quickly so in this case like
pancreas
we generally perform we generally
yes perform ngs
after one or two blood sample and repeat
the same analysis
with ngs before the first months of
clinical follow-up another cancer
like as i said before title cancer that
are generally characterized by
an indolent progression
we perform ngs one time
every six months so in this case
the schedule is a little bit
spread over time it depends
firstly on the type of tumor and
secondly also it depends on the
condition of the patient
within our institutional molecular to
more board we were able to
face with different patients in
different situations
generally metastatic patients need to be
analyzed by ngs more frequently than
patients that are objective for example
surgery so patients that are at earlier
stage of the disease in the ladder we
generally prefer
to do an ngs analysis of
tissue and angiospec line
and then analyze in terms of molecular
behavior
the blood sample we collect
after surgery for example job by digital
pcr
to monitor specifically for example care
of mutation
in the colon cancer setting or
the hfr mutation in the lung cancer
phase
so the right answer could be it depends
on the type of tumor and
the condition of the patient cannot
provide you a precise timeline outside
my experience
thank you dr allegretti and in the
take-home messages
you say that data from lb-based
approaches
must rely on both tissue and blood
samples
would you please explain a little bit
more why you see liquid biopsy as a
complementary technique to tissue biopsy
yes i showed you in some
of the previous slides an example of
this
uh general ngs panel
especially targeted on a
cover a list of sufficient targets for
example
40 game there are 40 gym panels that
span over all the actionable genes
but in some cases the amplicon
that uh that are entering this kind of
panel may not target the real
mutation that are present in tissue
and case number 19 i showed you
before it was a perfect example of that
so it case uh tissue
uh analytic tissue profiling may
complement
liquid bias but in general liquid biopsy
according to
what i said before about the timing of
sample of
tissue generally complement issue
analysis because what we can derive from
tissue may be maybe different
maybe yes
submitted to some changing over time for
example
during treatment and it reflects only a
past situation for example what we can
derive from the primary tumor it's
always before is always not modified by
the ongoing treatment after
the primary resection of the tumor so in
these cases
liquid biotin may complement issue
analysis because
it offers a precise picture of
this precise moment and not a pass
overview
in general liquid biopsy may also give
um may complement
visual analysis because it gives a
general
overview of the evolution of the tumor
so it could be easier for for example an
oncology
to assign other lines of therapy
based on an evaluation of the precise
moment of this precise moment
as compared to these additional lines of
therapy as the
original tumor profile because it was
influenced over time by the ongoing
treatment
thank you again dr alegretti for this
insightful q a session
now before we go i would like to thank
our audience for joining us and for
their interesting questions
we had quite a few questions come in
that we were unable to answer
so those we did not answer live today
and those submitted during our on demand
period
will be addressed via the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration
i would like to once again thank dr
matteo alegre for his time today
and his important research i would also
like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor thermo fisher scientific
for underwriting today's
educational webcast this webcast can be
viewed on demand
and labrets will alert you via email
when it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that's all for now
and we hope to see you again soon have a
great day